hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very very excited to finally have
brittany broski on the podcast today you
probably know her as kombucha girl uh
but she's so much more than that we talk
about everything on this podcast we talk
about her foyer into um
well college her traditional path of
going college into
um real adult job at an insurance
company to blowing up as a meme about
eating ass on the internet to getting
fired because of said meme but then meme
also creating a new path of career and
life it's a wild cinderella story if you
will uh and she also has just some
incredibly wise and
thoughtful
um thoughts for lack of a better word
about the world of social media of
influencer culture about the rise of
tick tock and where it's going to go in
the future and also um
an incredibly moving
pants shooting story so it's a little
bit of everything in this podcast oh
speaking of she's got a new podcast
violating community guidelines with her
friend sarah that's also got way more
information about all of the things on
the internet that might have
striked your fancy or caused you
curiosity at some point in your lives we
talk about all of it so please enjoy
this episode of not too deep with
brittany broski
[Music]
brittany it's so wonderful to talk to
you also um hello new extensions
hello miss hair she's not bald anymore
how are they doing how are you doing you
seem like a new person
i have reinvented my personality this is
britney 2.0 you know something they
don't tell you about
sew-in extensions oh yeah so it was like
little needles in my head i was trying
to sleep last night i was like
i know
yeah it's it's um all of it is a wild
experience i've had extensions but the
tape in for so long and they're like
medical grade tape and then when they
start to get gummy it's just this like
wad of gum and gluten i can't imagine
something worse actually glamour it's
all glamour and beauty is pain and it
takes a lot of money to look this cheap
and that's all you need to know about
the beauty industry
um brittany i want to talk about
everything but
first i kind of want to get more from
you of like backstory i'm curious about
you grew up in theater-ish
yeah so i was doing theater in high
school since probably i was like 14. i
joined the improv troupe little high
school improv oh yes um continued that
into college and then kind of gave it up
when i was like all right no more funny
business i'm a businesswoman
and then now i fart online for money so
life is crazy it's a beautiful
trajectory really for all artists out
there i feel like
i'm curious what your thoughts are about
uh theater communities do you miss it at
all did it like kind of uh give you some
wisdom and knowledge looking back oh it
definitely did you know what i do miss i
miss the um community like the
camaraderie of being in a show
altogether yeah and like the inside
jokes and you know
those short-lived but intense
friendships yeah um and then carrying
those into other shows i do miss that
and i do miss like improv in the sense
of
working especially now everything's
digital you know like being in person
with someone and just bantering and
bouncing off each other is just so
like wow yeah i miss that but i think i
get my fix of what theater gave me i get
that now from social media yeah yeah
yeah were there any productions that
stand out to you that you were a part of
that were either incredible or
absolutely terrible
oh 100
i would say majority terrible
um
i was in spamalot monty python spamalot
yeah the most fun ever like the most fun
ever the music is so
stupid and good and it's like set in
medieval times it was so much fun i
cross-dressed for all of it and for some
reason yeah my directors were always
like you would be good as either a 60
year old woman or a man
it was never anything other than that so
um yeah that was fun we did some
remember one act plays yes like the
competitions
uh lost every year i never did the
competitions what was that like that
seems intense it was a nationwide thing
depending on like the tier of your
school you know how many kids go to your
school or whatever okay um it was a
nationwide competition for just little
short one-act plays
and it was just i mean you're asking a
14 year old to be like okay you're
freshly divorced you have nothing left
to give like you're on the last thread
of life go it's like i'm 14 i have
homework due tomorrow yeah you don't
have to figure out what algebra is i
don't know what geometry is like i'm
just give me a second
like that is probably
oh my god i was just recently watching
it back with my family and i was like
i'm so sorry i made y'all sit through
this
i'll be supportive but oh my god
yeah that is crazy when you look back
and you zoom out a little bit you're
like this wasn't just about me like my
family had to experience it yeah this
was everyone suffered for me and i
appreciate that
um but you okay you kind of went a
traditional route in that i mean you
went to college and got a degree
yeah and you got a degree in
communications
yeah
i was a strategic com major with a
spanish minor oh very cool okay and so
what happened after college
so after college i my dream was to work
at a well my absolute dream was to make
super bowl commercials like do the
storyboard
yeah i wanted to like like geico
commercials or you know um
i think
geico really started that for me with
like the kids
and the gecko and all that like even
like flow from progressive where it's
these iconic things that you remember
they impacted culture yeah i wanted to
storyboard those commercials for the
super bowl wow but
obviously life doesn't work out that way
and so
instead of going into that like creative
marketing i worked at an insurance
brokerage okay because you got to pay
bills close to geico
yeah close just wrong end of the
spectrum of you know what i wanted to do
with insurance so
worked there um the most miserable
experience of my life
just awful i worked in customer service
and i was literally like on the headsets
all day i was like oh thank you for
calling to the insurance how can i help
you and it was just people bitching at
me
and i was 21 i just graduated so it was
awful and then i quit that job started
working at a bank
um a little less miserable but still
miserable and
then the kombucha video happened yeah
got fired
and then
talk to me about the kombucha video
happens i mean talking about changing
culture impacting society
how do you get fired after that
so she brought me in
my boss brought me in to her office
she's like this southern 59 year old
lady doesn't even know what youtube is
or so i thought because she's a damn
liar
she brought me and she was like
i i see you know what your face online
and it was tweets like me when i ate ass
for the first time yeah
she was like is this i was like that's
not me you have to understand that is
not me like that's how a meme works yeah
i create the content they create
captions yeah so
she was just so confused and she saw it
as a major liability to the company
because wow
this was a regional bank in north texas
i mean the next youngest employee after
me was like 50. wow like i was the
youngest employee there
this was tick tock was not anything what
it was today this was right summer of
2019 it was still musically basically at
that point yeah
and she was just so confused by you know
what i was doing online i was like trust
me it's harmless like it's it's just a
viral thing it'll be gone in two months
and she decided nope like this is a
major liability we're gonna let you go
so i got fired because i was [ __ ]
around online
i mean yeah i can imagine that she hears
viral and thinks virus and thinks
infection and this is going to ruin the
company yeah
so what do you do from there like how
were you kind of like i'm going to
pursue internet stuff digital
like content creation or were you kind
of like
i gotta figure out life maybe this is a
side thing
uh definitely the latter i literally was
like well i need to put in an
application at outback steakhouse in the
meantime while i'm applying for other
corporate jobs because it was so
humiliating having to call my parents
and be like
i just got fired from my job at the bank
like i was so embarrassed i was crying
and because you know like i graduated
college in three years like i've always
been like the smart kid it was just so
humiliating because i was
online i got fired like that's so
humiliating and so i didn't even have
time to put in an app at uh outback
steakhouse because i got my first brand
deal around that time and then from
there
it hasn't stopped knock on wood
yeah it's just been it has been a
whirlwind nonstop and i really haven't
had any other thought other than okay
this is my job now yeah
you kind of have to take it on decide to
like 100 percent say yes and to the
situation
the uh i continue to do that i'm so
interested because you said that
you had an initial interest in like
storyboarding
commercials specifically for the super
bowl
and then when brands approach you having
that kind of like brain already it must
be interesting how you approach brand
deals is there like a system that you
put in place are there certain brands
that you like want to vet and like work
with specifically like how do you how do
you manage that
well i think it all goes kind of back to
catholic culture yeah and not even
cancer culture but just like the culture
that we exist and of people being hyper
aware of
the footprint that brands and companies
leave on us and on the world and
there is a
a sensitivity to you know like if i'm
going to work with a clothing company
and they're known for using child labor
or whatever yeah that's going to be the
top comment on that video and i never
thought about that you know because it's
like oh this company's offering me money
hell yeah we'll take it right it's free
money for me to make fart noises into
the camera but it's not that it's not
that simple you know because when you
have an audience as large as we do
there's a responsibility that comes with
that if i am personally endorsing these
brands that's not just them handing the
check
i am using
my trust that i've established with my
followers to endorse this company that i
sometimes know nothing about yeah and so
that that was a learning curve for me
because it's money many money it's no no
yeah right like if you're pushing a
product or a brand it better be the
right one and so i have dream brands
that i'd like to work with but
i've had some stumbles and falls you
know working with companies that ended
up being
less than optimal and now it's on record
i'm endorsing them so
it's been it's a strange thing i never
thought i'd have to think about it like
that yeah but i think it's so important
that you do think about it and that you
are saying how important it is to think
about because
yeah it's it's one of those things where
you can get thrown into it and you have
to figure it out after a problem happens
or right you can really understand that
you're kind of this like a billboard you
were the pr person and the talent and
the face yeah everything pouring myself
out these brands
yeah which is just so wild because like
the idea of content creator as like a
professional job is yes you're creating
fun content here and there but the way
you actually make a living doing it is
primarily working with brands so this is
like such a major part of the actual
content creator
job to keep it going
and you just have to become more and
more kind of like scrutinizing of like
yourself and your value versus what this
brand's value is
yeah do you ever like
look at
major like a-list celebrities and think
i wonder either i wonder how much they
got paid or do they really actually care
about this product because now i think
about it like that yeah i think a little
bit of both i think i
i guess my assumption before was always
that celebrities kind of had these
people
wrangling them into these situations and
so they had much many more brains and
eyes to consider what this opportunity
is where a lot of content creators it's
really on them unless they
build out a team around them which is
you know a difficult thing to do
um and so yeah i still look at
celebrities i feel like celebrities
because of influencer culture are forced
to operate as individuals more than like
you know this walking doll that gets
positioned every sure
yeah it's very and especially now with
you know the state of instagram and tick
tock and all that like celebs are so
accessible almost to like a scary degree
yeah you should not be able to tweet
gwyneth paltrow
why did you make a candle that smells
like your vagina it blows my mind that
there's access to everyone everywhere
all the time if i get too high at night
i get really freaked out about all of
that
and i have to very true
like a doomsday prepper like turn off
all my devices and not really think
about it too much
yeah um okay i'm also curious about uh
you and sarah you guys met
through social media
yeah so um
sarah and i are
cousins
[Laughter]
that made it more complicated for me to
understand
you lost
yeah we met on twitter um
well i had been a fan of her forever
because i followed her on vine yeah um
and then i knew she made youtube videos
and i tweeted after i got fired and i
was accumulating all there was one day
in august 2019 where i gained
93 000 twitter followers in one day like
in a 24-hour period oh that's
overwhelming it was it was like i had no
[ __ ] idea what was happening and i
was just kind of going with the flow
yeah i got fired um started making money
online and then my lease was up in texas
and i was like
man do i just bite the bullet and just
do it just move to l.a and so i tweeted
i was like let's say hypothetically i
moved la you know who would anyone want
to be my roommate
sarah me
and so we started dming and i'm like you
know like two bedrooms she's like yeah
i'm like do any pet she's like i've got
a cat i'm like well i'm allergic but we
can make it work you know we're just
going back and forth and so soon enough
she flies out to la starts touring
places
we sign a place i meet her for the first
time ever in person the day we move in
wow
and it has been fantastic i mean it was
such a i think the universe provides
sort of thing but the first video we
ever made together on youtube
we started this bit that were cousins
and people people still to this day are
like
you know when you see people arguing in
your comment section yes it'll be like
well they're cousins that make sense
like something well they are cousins not
like no exactly
i love it keep the mythology alive
people want to believe
no you guys have recently created a
podcast together
yeah so for people that don't know
what's the concept behind it
so because sarah and i are children of
the internet for better or worse
um we realized that that's such a niche
experience for a lot of people you know
like growing up
with the internet raising us like there
are so many things that i have seen in
my life that my parents know nothing
about it because i've been online things
i've been exposed to like things i've
you know the media that kind of raised
me and sarah has a very well the same
experience yeah and so we were like you
know we want to do a podcast there's
kind of the demand for it and what would
be the concept and so it is that it's
exploring these little
micro trends or throwbacks from the
internet um not so much like hey guys
2006 remember this the beginning of
youtube it's more like do you remember
that weird [ __ ] thing that went viral
in 2012 like what happened to that so
it's that
um
it's educational but it's also riffing
and it's banter like it's a comedy
podcast above all else because the
internet is the internet is so
ridiculous absolutely so it's called
violating community guidelines very
fitting perfect perfect
and it's all about um internet stuff we
talk about furries
fan fiction
um we've got one coming out about um
being horny online
like just people being unabashedly horny
i feel like that's yeah and uh
a whole podcast in and of itself oh yeah
truly has there been anything
that you've just like that stands out to
you that you've discovered you guys talk
about conspiracy theories
um the furry community
uh anything that you've learned that you
didn't really understand before
you know i do have a newfound
appreciation for the furry community
yeah people already think i'm a furry
because i'm like okay some pixar
characters are really hot like and i'm
not the only one to say that like you
guys are lying
people are like just say it you're a
furry okay i will
um
that was like to realize actually how
much of a
community it is worldwide yeah it was
kind of like oh you know what i mean
because i belong i have belonged to so
many different fandoms and groups online
and to realize that like that's just
another one and there's this weird
stigma around it i was like period
furries are just living their best lives
and we've just judged them for any
reason they just found a place of
acceptance and we're like no
no no no
not here yeah you guys shouldn't be able
to express the things you find the most
joy within
how dare you absolutely not
um
how
i'm curious too with i guess with the
podcast you probably uh have more of a
chance to just kind of uneditedly talk
about things discuss things how is that
experience versus you know making
content on other platforms
you know what it's it's freeing in the
sense that we can just have a
conversation and
people can see it you know segway from
okay they were talking about this and
now they're talking about you know it's
just a conversation and that's
that
format is acceptable yeah versus on
youtube
and even on tick tock i feel like it has
to be
hit hit hit joke joke joke and then
you're done yeah on it's so much more
freeing to just be able to talk with
like one of my closest friends about
things that we both
go through
how it affects society how it affects us
as women you know things like that it's
just so nice yeah but there is that fear
that you know
online we know that people don't
understand nuance
so
we have our editor cut out some stuff
that's like that could be interpreted so
you know polar opposite of how we meant
it just take it out like it's scary
because people could take that clip and
you're done you're done
yeah it is becoming like a forefront
consideration now that you have to
really
imagine how the audience sees you
we have to think five steps ahead yeah
so it's interesting that you guys get to
like be fully formed people with fully
thought out ideas that aren't just you
know jump cut jump cut use this editing
tool right but at the same time you're
like
now they hear all my ideas i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm speaking freely
scary
maybe censorship is the good thing i
don't know
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back i'm so curious
your kind of experience with tick-tock
and just general kind of thoughts about
that platform so we're going to talk
about that when we get back
[Music]
great we're back in
now
you
were on tick-tock before like you said
when it was more of a musically thing
and then it's now
you know pandemic etc become like the
platform i'm curious what your
experience has been just watching it
kind of morph and change and grow and
get like infiltrated with people
yeah i
i talk about this for a long time i
think um
tick tock's humble beginnings as this
sort of like strange
cosplay platform
for people who were like acting
but also just horny teens who were
residuals from musically yeah to watch
it go from that
to tick-tock influences culture i mean
isn't that their their
slogan like we make culture or something
like that probably sounds like it um
it's very true i mean i it's hard to
think about a time where
the top 40 billboard top 40 wasn't all
tick tock songs
you know what i mean like it just
completely changed
life yeah how we
you know view celebrities how we view
entertainment how we view
money and creators making money online
brands online i mean it's just changed
everything in the music industry as well
like
labels now have a budget aside for like
okay we're gonna promote that on tick
tock like it's a tick tock budget yeah
so
it's just insane i think i i feel very
very fortunate to be a part of the story
of tick-tock yeah because when the
kombucha video went viral um it i
uploaded it to a tick tock so it was
watermarked for the tick tock logo so it
was circulating on all these platforms
and people were like what the what is
that logo yeah and it was tick-tock and
so
when articles would write about the
phenomenon and all that they'd be like
uploaded to tick-tock people like what
the [ __ ] is that
so they and tick-tock acknowledges it
too and i feel very blessed because
they're like you're you're a part of the
history of it so yeah
um
other than that i feel like today
it is so um
humbling to
watch like major celebrities like reese
witherspoon get on tick tock and try to
like you know what are we doing on here
what dr phil you're calling me daddy in
the comments it's like what the [ __ ] is
dr phil on this talk we don't need it
who's asking for it
i mean that's uh that's what i'm so
curious about because i mean you've been
a part of it and also a bystander
watching it grow and morph and change
like what's your
uh
i guess
method or strategy or way in which you
use tick tock now do you change the
content that you upload do you think
about
what you're going to do differently or
do you just kind of do you and then let
everyone figure it out
yeah tick tock is all the minute i start
thinking of tick tock is like a serious
thing yeah it's not going to be fun
anymore yeah um there came a time as it
comes with ever creator i'm sure you can
attest to it too of when numbers become
more important than
the content yeah and so there came a
point in time where i was like
would this hit a million views in 24
hours
who the [ __ ] cares yeah
cares why am i thinking about it like
that like and it still is in the back of
my mind constantly because how can it
not be you know when we
view our existences now as numbers yeah
um
and so i i
think about it more as like i'm posting
these for me
yeah and i have two accounts and my main
account you know i sometimes get hung up
on numbers still to this day and i try
not to but on my
spam account i'll post 40 videos in an
hour and i don't give a [ __ ] how they do
because it's my brain
i have to get it out yeah
and those do better than the ones on my
main account and so it's like it's all
just you can't predict it right no one
knows what's going on you can act like
you do but no one really does i agree
yeah it's just a matter of are you
having fun it really i know and that
sounds so cliche to say but it's
something i really resonate with because
it does become
it's hard to balance the idea that this
is your job and it's also the means in
which you have fun expressing yourself
and to reconcile those two things
constantly is very difficult because
they're very much at odds with each
other
so constantly all the time there is not
like
oh my god and especially making branded
content you know where it's like be
yourself but for our brand
yeah yeah but it's gonna say paid
advertisement but just like be you know
what you would do
right keep it organic
[ __ ] does that mean
uh i'm also curious too because you've
kind of you know like
fallen forward into this um
content creator world were there any
surprises or interesting things to you
about getting to know content creators
seeing more like the behind the scenes
kind of stuff about everything versus
you know being raised by all of it yeah
you want to know what was the biggest
like i was like ew it kind of like left
a bad taste in my mouth of course i do
how um collabs work
a lot of the times like i didn't realize
when you see collabs on youtube that's
the first time they're ever meeting in
person
i've been offered to do collabs and
that's it it's like you're gonna go over
to bubble bust house like their
assistant's going to get you from the
parking garage like
we're gonna
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
like i that is so cringy and i never
thought about it like that when i was
only a a viewer you know like a
spectator i was like oh you know here's
a celebrity and a celebrity and they're
just you know whatever they have to be
friends no girl
and it's just very awkward um
you've met a lot of people where i'm
like you are so not personable
how do you have a career i know that's
like the years of vidcon were always
very
um
a lot going on a lot of seeing things uh
that met or didn't meet expectations or
like preconceived notions of things uh
and yeah that was kind of for me the
harder thing of watching the industry of
it develop and because in the beginning
it was like maybe we were meeting for
the first time doing a collab but we
have been communicating for a while
no one had assistance no one's paying
each other anything right everyone's
just like of good grace is going over
and being like i like you and what you
do
and if you like me let's make something
together right
it was a much more innocent um
you know like nature of content creator
relations and i feel like even five six
years ago yeah totally so you and james
charles are good friends
the best of friends that's my assumption
uh period
i yeah are there any people that you
haven't collaborated with yet that are
on like your short list or
is that something you don't really think
about often
no written link let me on go mythical
morning now or else
that's what i have to say yeah i feel
like that should have happened years ago
i love that i grew up watching them i i
just love them so much and they are such
role models for you know how to create a
career from this [ __ ] and create a
career a live tour music book they're on
jimmy fallon they have
so many like side projects it's they've
done it so perfectly i agree they're
inspiring in their ability to stay
authentic to themselves humble and
hardworking and just very
thoughtful about everything they didn't
agree more could not agree more um then
for sure um
emma chamberlain i love him at
chamberlain
i would love to collab with her but i
know she's very um particular yeah about
that sort of thing so
none taken
in an alternate universe could you ever
see yourself as a social media manager
absolutely not
when you think about like by and large
how insufferable a lot of creators are i
couldn't do it i couldn't have them be
like
my car didn't come on time my post page
is shut up dude i think about some of
the stuff i complained about and i'm
like i'm like just kill me yeah like i
am oh my god if i ever sound ungrateful
just kill me
i
i love your humility so much
um
okay
now i'm gonna get into the two questions
i ask every single guest that is on the
podcast um the first is who alive or
dead would you most like to throw cold
spaghetti
throw cold spaghetti at
okay so that's a great question because
that's like you don't want to cause them
physical harm
it's entirely your intention i will say
you can throw it with whatever emotion
it feels appropriate to you and also
that to me this is an answer that
changes all the time it's not
necessarily the one
set in stone person it might be just who
comes to mind in this moment
all i'm thinking about is shawn evans
from hot ones
yeah that would be good i don't yeah i
don't mean it just like a sean evans i
don't like you i mean it is like
i would love to see sean i i want to sit
across from him at the hot ones table
throw cold spaghetti at him and see him
try to like reroute the interview
you know what i mean like he is so good
i want to like throw him a curve ball
and have him be like all right well as a
lover of cold spaghetti when you were 11
years old what did you
in a beautiful way i would love to see
that to be very honest um i think it
could happen
um the other question that i ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story
or like a bathroom emergency situation
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases to describe the
event um oh i can't i can't tell the
actual story okay well you can it's
entirely up to you if you'd like to
after giving us like the three little
situations um you're more than welcome
to elaborate but i never want anyone to
feel uncomfortable
um okay
the short version is gas station
i35
oh okay okay
i mean
uh that does tell a lot but i would love
to hear the elaboration if you if you'd
like to
so um i was on a
road trip from visiting a friend down in
my
houston austin something i was driving
back to dallas okay
and i had just gotten to dallas because
it's like i-45 and then it's i-35 and
i-35 is just a big spaghetti bowl of
roads so confusing
all i had to eat that day was takis red
bull and a coke zero oh god
my stomach was gurgling gurgling and
burbling and i had been driving for like
four hours and i just it was it hit you
know like when the diarrhea hit oh yeah
i uh did not make it in time and i a
little little dude who came out in the
pants pulled over at a shell station and
just went to town in the bathroom and it
was just i mean you know it's like do i
throw my underwear away
or do i just like make it i was probably
12 minutes from my house i was like i
couldn't have waited well dude i lasted
four hours i couldn't waited 12 more
minutes oh no
got sharted charted bad
that's i it is to me in those moments
really miraculous the way
the human brain starts to problem solve
and starts to like
it blows my mind of like the
i could never be macgyver because the
way my brain problem solves in those
situations is like do i make
uh do i do like a
a challenge like they do on drag race
where i'm now making toilet paper rolls
into new pants to walk out of this gas
station
am i fastening the toilet paper uh lid
seat yeah exactly
makeshift underwear yeah
and how do i pay them as i walk out the
door um how do you say sorry without
saying sorry oh gosh the you're also
really close with um
tons of drag queens how did this happen
you know i it's the hag effect i don't
know it's literally i cannot describe it
like it's the michelle visage effect
since
middle school yeah i have always been
the closest with gay men
it's just something i think maybe
because i'm just
so
unapologetically you know whoever i am
yeah whatever comes out i don't
apologize for it and i think that that's
very
attractive for someone who has been told
that their existence is
not wanted and you know not normal and
that it does so to see someone
kind of living
at a hundred percent capacity all the
time yeah i think that i i've always
just been attracted to
the lgbtq community and and
you know they find
a form of comfort and escapism in me and
my content so
it's a blessing honestly because
the love that i get from that community
is i feel so accepted and i can only
hope to provide that too so i honestly
don't know it kind of happened
organically i've been a fan of drag race
for forever sarah and i did a video on
my channel of us recreating trixie and
cocky makeup just god-awful just like
borderline hate crime
and
um trixie saw it because we tagged them
in it like thinking that they wouldn't
tracy saw it invited us over to her
house
we filmed the video i think it's sitting
at like 9 million views now or something
stupid like that and from there it just
kind of became this staple where
everyone was like oh you're trick she's
young or whatever and then i work with
wow presents now uh it's like the the
production company that puts on drag i
mean it's just wild so i think it was
bound to happen and i'm just so every
day i'm like i can't believe it's real
what are your thoughts on the current
season
i do love bosco yeah yeah those i do
love costco yes
um and i think willowpill is gonna
she's gonna
i don't know she's got some tricks for
her sleeve i have not seen the most
recent
two episodes i don't think so i need to
catch up i might be one behind but i'm
with you i think willowpill surprises me
i really didn't expect
uh for them to be such a beautiful
little weirdo i really i know right
and rue loves those that the ones that
push the boundaries of drag and what
drag can be yeah it's always so
interesting that you can see in the
beginning of a season like who rue
obviously has like a deep affection for
it they're like 100 percent a little
biased but okay
yeah like this don't really feel fair
but it's your show i guess you know it's
fun it's your empire
[Music]
okay now we're gonna get into a section
uh called deep and hot where i'm gonna
ask you a deep question that we have
prepared for you and then ask you
uh for a hot take on kind of like a
topic that we have prepared for you okay
all right let's do it absolutely no
wrong answers
um okay deep question is
is happiness the goal
no
um it's not why is that um because if
you set happiness as your goal you're
constantly gonna be disappointed and
you're gonna feel like a failure
because i don't think the purpose of
life is to be
happy i think that that is a byproduct
if you're lucky
um
yeah that's the that's a really
that's a good question that's a very
cool answer
yeah well i mean if you strive your
whole life to just seek happiness
so many things are left in the wayside
you know and and
i think the balanced human experience is
to experience that's what makes us human
is sorrow and depression and anger and
happiness and joy and i mean it's just
like that is what separates us from
every other sentient being so
i i think yeah that's that's a great
question i love that answer
um especially in the whirlwind of so
much self-help
information
touted online uh
sometimes just
wears me down and yeah do you feel that
way too it's like a toxic
positivity yeah i
it's a very
it's frustrating sometimes i don't know
what the right answer is to because some
people might genuinely be living great
lives following these kind of
ways of thinking and lifestyle choices
um does it work for me
because i'm with you in the sense that i
feel like
feeling
everything is part of existing
and to strive for only one feeling
versus the rest feels a bit inauthentic
i guess right and when it's also like if
you're happy all the time
you sometimes forget how happy you are
because if that's your new normal right
i just like i
to to make it kind of personal you know
i never could have appreciated what i do
now and the friends i have now and just
what i get to do as my career
if i had graduated college and
immediately started doing this like i am
so thankful for the period in my life
where i worked in nine to five yeah and
i was [ __ ] miserable like i hated my
life
to have that as a point of reference to
now i am so it just like it
emphasizes those emotions even more just
like i am so grateful and i'm so joyous
yeah so
i think you need it all absolutely it's
very grounding to have that perspective
um okay hot take for you kind of touched
on a little bit already um i guess just
what you
think or imagine if you have any of
these thoughts about the future of tick
tock i mean it's hard to have predicted
any of where
it's grown or how it's changed but if
you have any thoughts on the future
future of tick tock okay well i think
maybe this is a hot take um
i think tick tock has staying power
the way that you know
youtube does yeah um
especially as they listen to the
audience and
make adjustments to the app accordingly
you know like the three-minute feature
came out we were like [ __ ] yeah
um the text to speech feature yeah
captions they're making it more
accessible every day and more
user-friendly every day and more you
know as a creator seeing all the new
effects and and features is cool it's
like more tools to create with
um
i i do think it has staying power but
that's only if they continue on that
trajectory whatever snapchat has done
like remember snapchat from five six
years ago vaguely i i didn't just
literally
yeah you weren't missing much it
literally was just sending pictures back
and forth to your friends and like being
able to message them yeah now there's
like reality shows on snapchat there's
you can see the news on snapchat
you can you know there's like a
geolocation feature there's an emoji
bitmoji
i just don't [ __ ] know dude i open
snapchat and i'm like what is this
if tick tock does that
it's over yeah people are going to lose
interest because you're overloading them
yes
fun fun fun no girl
no
i think that's a beautiful hot take i
love that
uh we've gotten towards the very end of
the podcast which is wild because i feel
like i've just scratched the surface of
getting into your brain about everything
we could talk for hours i know truly um
thank you for all this uh wise words
information and life story before we
wrap up completely we like to give our
guests a little token of our
appreciation for being here and that is
a um personalized horoscope from us to
you
but we're not we're not astrologers at
all so take a green assault you could
just be like i read an article one time
and i'd be like tell me now
um melissa put it in the chat for you if
you'd like to read it
you're taurus full of the stars period
refer to me as that when i enter a room
wretchedness i'm not getting
the sun enters pisces and your social
zone on friday i'm probably gonna start
my period so expect to be busy with
friends and socializing for the next
month period if that sounds exhausting
just know it's your own damn fault
so y'all type this
maybe
we're not astrologers
we let the stars
uh inform
what we i'm a vessel yes
grace is a vessel the universe speaks
through her that's all it is that's how
it's been my whole life
uh thank god brittany thank you so much
for making time and having this chat um
i love you [ __ ] i've always loved you
this is
i'm so excited that you were able to do
this um for people that don't know
where can they find you follow you
listen to the podcast etc
so first and foremost our podcast is
called violating community guidelines it
is everywhere you get your podcast and
we also upload on youtube so go watch it
on youtube because that counts as a
download from me
thank you guys so much
um and then you can find me on britney
underscore broski
britney spelled the english way and
broski like
like broski
you know what i mean for audio listeners
i just dabbed myself up it's perfect
well thank you again brittany this has
been so fun thank you guys of course and
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep
not too deep
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music